good morning Millennials the prince who
was promised to us via The Bachelor via
ABC who was actually never delivered to
us for reasons unbeknownst to us it's
finally being delivered to the most
premium warning show the morning toast
please welcome to the very prestigious
stage the one the only Peter Krause and
Peter craftsman if you are the only
person now who's been on our show three
times one of there's been a few it's a
very exclusive club
Alexis waters yeah okay no Alexis waters
this is twice maybe Amana Stan maybe no
no we have to look back our records yeah
I turned my back to a part of a small
club we're so happy to have you here
with so happy to kick off the show with
you truly as the toasters know we're
gonna have the longest show of all time
today so much to discuss so much News
Bachelorette everybody's just but we
have our priorities in order and you're
at the top of our list Wow always I I'm
honored that thank you so we're so happy
to have you here yeah happy to be here
how are you fantastic always okay so I'm
still in Madison still traveling country
doing boot camps I got one here in New
York in two days now you're an Ironman I
have done higher man three times wow you
seem fun I didn't do this pastime so
it's just in Hawaii just to spectate and
work with that yeah hand out water kind
of tell us things that you alright so
where's your bootcamp gonna be this week
at brick so it's in Midtown is it sold
out already we have not opened up
tickets yet what a very small grouping
so you should I do like 100 to 200
people this is just me like 30 or 40 and
how can people find tickets cuz I know
can't yeah but I'll put some Instagram
so I'll put it up on like a story or
maybe on a page or some like that okay I
someone who has personally done a kaput
camp I'm like snitch who ditched me it's
a premium working out experience and if
someone who's never experienced a
bootcamp in their entire life and has
absolutely no intentions to I've seen
Peter Krause with his shirt off and it's
a premium experience right yeah it's
definitely motivational you at the very
least it's like I don't teach with my
shirt off I'll promise that well maybe
if you did so where have you done them
so far like around the country where you
headed to next actually there's nothing
planned as of yet we're working on one
for the southeast corner of the states
but Miami Chicago New York a bunch of
times LA
Antonio no you gotta do Dallas
Austin is also a great place you menage
you've got a joint tour where it's like
the skinny people can go hang out with
you and then like the fun people who
like to drink any doughnuts can come to
my show and then like we'll do karaoke
no we're back we're not paid over oh and
then drink and laugh but maybe it
actually would be more beneficial to do
it after you hang out with me because
that's where the real work needs to be
done yeah but then they might be drunk
which would you do people throw up at
your boot camps never had anybody throw
up that you saw that I know of yeah so
the boot camps are set up in a way
they're like everybody can do them
because they're all bodyweight they're
easily modified so if someone can't do
something I simply give a modification
and they do that instead so if it's
beyond your fitness level
you'll be okay like I will never do a
burpee for the rest of my life that is
beyond my fitness level and I feel like
I can get into shape by never having to
do a burpee again so that's why I feel
just got like I feel like I can get into
shape without ever doing exercise I'm
telling you like I'm well on my way yeah
any York I feel like that's true you got
to put in like fifteen thousand steps a
day in this city no I'm not talking
about with any physical movement yeah
you can you can lose weight but getting
like in shape is a different solution
that's true that's true I just feel like
I'm gonna get a six-pack without ever
lifting a big and I'm gonna get a
six-pack without ever doing a burpee
after I'm dead like wow how was she such
an amazing physical shape and she never
even set foot on a treadmill it's gonna
you Peter
are you totally gonna get to see me
naked when I'm dead are you gonna donate
your body to science no I'm gonna donate
my body to Peter Cross yes and so do we
on the show actually or how do you feel
about the war on the term diet oh my god
such a great question cuz you need can't
say it any more the word yeah word yeah
we do well so I think anything that's
specific to diet typically short-lived
like if you're on a diet you are already
in a like a mindset that it's something
that you have to do you have to do
something then you're probably gonna be
resistant to it so I say versus like
having a diet you just have like a clean
eating habit
like a healthy eating habit it's
something that's habitual and that
you're continuing it throughout the rest
of your life so you're replacing the D
word with the H word a good habit takes
28 days to develop and then from that
time on hopefully you can consistently
take that throughout the rest your life
but can you have like breaks in between
like wake up what are you what's up my
meals are all different I mean depending
on where I'm at in the country what's
available to me a lot of times I eat at
Starbucks I ate a banana because I
needed something real quick every day
you make up what is it you ever cheat
you ever see what Mark Wahlberg eats a
dozen today he makes up at 2:00 a.m.
it's the weirdest thing
what he's feeding himself really no no
literally has 10 meals a day what do you
do so I believe in a balanced meal at
every single sitting so that snacks or
meals doesn't when I sit a lot
[Laughter]
throughout the week prayer like 5 or 6
somewhere there and then on the weekends
as late as like 10 or 11 wow that's good
so when you wake up my 5 or 6 like is it
torture to get up or like you're like I
fall asleep I like 11:00 or midnight
yeah it never gets easier even the
person who's the picture of health has a
hard time waking yeah okay so what are
you doing 6:00 this morning what am i
doing so a carbohydrate which in that
case would be the oatmeal toast or
potatoes and then oh me too smart
sometimes you know it's a little
different than your kind of just toast
none what did you do read or you do
complex complex carbohydrates all
depends what my goal is okay like
nutrition could be pretty complex if you
really start to get into it like what
are your health goals for some fitness
goals
so like eating for fitness for seating
for health are very different right
Michael Phelps eats a lot of carbs but
like and he eats very simple carbs
because he needs energy quickly versus
someone who is sitting more often would
want more complex like me eating the
carbs that Michael Phelps says which I
do in cakes and donuts what I can do is
the same for you at they would that's
upsetting you know a
that's just that's like unfair that's
biology or something like Instagram
kills means because you'll see these
super fit people posting all about like
their doughnuts in their cakes and all
kind of and then it makes the average
person feel bad about themselves like
why and I can't do that well because
that's not how your body like uses the
nutrients that's getting so they're
using that instantly either as
replenishment or for future nutrients
doing it for the gram Instagram is tough
place there's a lot of people that can
make like fake social-media followings
based on what they kind of like put out
there versus what they're actually doing
yeah you guys really aren't that funny
in person online terrible terrible
terrible by the way I'm gonna be at the
Wilbur theater this Thursday in Boston
tickets fail block are one job done I'm
just kidding they're sold out good Peter
cross any more questions for you yeah so
talking about building and brands on
Instagram have no feel how do you feel
as if it's difficult to come from the
background that you come from which is
thatch allure um we're just like people
like me who just like want to see like
take a shirt off and stuff whereas
people who like actually want to like
actively get into shape what is the
hardest part of like building a brand
yes you're coming from an actor I didn't
really build a brand so I feel like I've
stayed consistent with who I am all
throughout I've always been fitness and
health but not overbearing I don't
believe that anybody needs to be like
pounded with a constant message of like
you have to be fit you have to be
healthy you have to be doing this in
this to be the better person versus I do
what makes you happy or at least like
comfortable in your own skin so
hopefully I can give a couple tips here
and there that way along that process
well that's simply trade you for me now
that we know you so well you really
remain the same since The Bachelor from
the first time you came on until now you
still have like the same priorities and
the same personality and you know the
same love for us right and staying that
way even though like you were a very big
fan favorite from bathroom sir
sure so many people wanted to see you
want do TV you're like I don't know ex
on the beach whatever shows people did
I'm sure you've turned down many many a
trashed reality show I think not a lot
how many there's been a couple things in
there excellent Beach 100% I've never
heard of that right bachelor paradise
probably yes I was around never know The
Bachelor maybe yeah
but you know what I just feel like you
are gonna be like another salt and
pepper are aligned egg like in a couple
of years like when we need you when big
are in Lauren B fans I just feel like in
a couple years like you're gonna give
the people what they want and you know
what I'm I'm excited that I mean I hope
we'll see are you in a relationship I'm
not it alright how often do the one
dates uh less I tried you for a little
bit but it it's really difficult you
know to play so look once a month less
right like once every two weeks how do I
mean build yeah online friends friends
people have known for a long time they
just like never proceeded in our
relationship do you ever open your DMS
looking for a date no are you on any
dating apps yes that's great which one
to download is it is it for us rule of
Ryan you can't talk about it I believe
so I was never not even looking JD
you're not even looking at me cuz you
don't want me to keep telling about
right no he was afraid of riot no he
said what is Riya
what is Fight Club I guess II never got
accepted like I need to get on riot just
to make some like a business connect
right there needs to be Raya fizz I've
heard you can also do business
connections just for friends of a zalaya
okay well I'm definitely not gonna
accept it now right well I don't know
free press I think they don't want right
so have you been in any relationship
since the show no question okay you're
just so fitness focused on your business
I'm just very busy guy traveling all the
weekends makes that tough and so thank
you yeah he's been trouble sometimes
would the last thing let's not talk
about him and it's out of the picture
okay the first time I really like him
husband what's that the first time you
were here you said thank you were
looking like you're I dream girl was a
brunette who wasn't on The Bachelor is
that still your type of good memory we
tried to put her on Colton season but we
never actually went you didn't keep up
like do you care to have an opinion on
Colton being selected as a bachelor
I'll see things that are posted on
social media but that's about it you
don't watch a show not really I've seen
episodes here and there but it's not
something I'm focused on that honestly
same I shipped too much going on yeah
sure
zero belief in it watch for this but it
really has become tough ever since you
left and it's not even that you left
ever since they just like they still
miss Eltham
I failed us they tell the people so I
told you this backstage but I just want
to say it again because I thought it was
funny I really tried super hard to every
tollens need to come this morning she
landed at 9:30 but in Newark and it just
it wasn't gonna work I wanted to
surprise you both and then probably have
again but like the premium content
would've been so putting in like I would
have been okay with it but let's you
haven't run into Rachel Lindsay since
though since the eyelash on the floor
I've not spoken to her I've not seen her
or nothing no no do you guys call each
other on Instagram I don't have any do
you stay in contact with your exes you
don't have any accident no Ben was first
I went on a date with what no so pure
and lovely I think let's say Rachel is
you came here and we set you two down
like what would you say to her I have no
idea right good question
we wouldn't mediate for sure for so but
and I feel like the only people who
could bring you two like to a friendship
would be us because we love you both so
much equals some like so much respect
for both like if someone put a gun to my
head and said who do you like more I
really would ship well thank you for
taking a bullet maybe one day it'll
happen maybe but probably just everyone
who tried to make it happen today well
we've got to run into each other at some
point I know I mean I'm in Los Angeles
wha I'm in New York a lot I assume she
is - yeah no she's all and you guys are
both in New York this week so let's
Trippi by the way you came bearing gifts
for the toasters did you not the
committees yeah you're very welcome
yeah bring it over here sure show us
what we're working with well alright so
I'm working with Branco commits us it's
a botanical line for eczema you got acne
dandruff there's one yeah on red hair
and it's like so much harder to see like
the tantric on darker yeah but actually
that bird if I had it but I use just the
acne line okay yeah and so the idea is
there's there's three products say for
the actus you have like a cleanser then
you have your lotion and then you have a
spot really like it replenishes your
skin and it replaces like the good cells
that your body needs versus some of
these other things like let's say for my
acne treatment if i were to go into a
store needs like a lotion that could be
bleached and like my eyes that could be
parabens always so many chemicals right
so this has salicylic acid say wrong
salicylic acid salicylic acid and it
just helps to like reduce inflammation
one of the cool things there's rhubarb
in it so it's again like all botanicals
it's like natural right so it's as close
to Earth this you can get which like
going back to the nutrition like concept
if you put something in your body that
it's healthy for you internally why
wouldn't you do the same extra right I
feel like the skin is an organ let's me
not forget the dermis actually the
largest organ yes Jackie your epidermis
is showing a children's show no but like
I feel like this is what we always take
as people always ask us like what we do
for our skin and like it's gotten so
over complicated like people literally
put like [ __ ] the most ratchet
chemicals on their face because they
think it's gonna work where it's like
less is so much more less is more so one
thing is like this has a very natural
color smell all that to it which you'll
notice right away like a lot of times
you get lotions from the store that I
have you're like a white texture to it
or not texture like color and then we're
texture and then they also have a very
strong send this is a lemon what color
should it should it I look like a
brownish like a blueish okay
right and it shouldn't smell good
because that's just an additional
chemical that's unnecessary smell follow
just like clean like it smells like an
herb that you'd pick right which is my
like perfume how you pick your thing at
the store like you smell them all and
you pick the best mountain one but
that's really irrelevant yeah
for example I broke my cologne bottle on
the way here and I got my toothbrush put
that toothbrush in my mouth anymore of
course why would you put that on your
skin that's just gonna get all over your
stuff yeah everything's thanks it's
Peter Crescent natural scent oh my god
by the way you're just talking about
this right before it's being and putting
good things in your body the last time
you were here was also the last time I
ever drank vodka because Peter Krause
convinced me I just I was going back and
forth you can't do both you either a
person who drinks tequila or you're a
person who drinks vodka and I was always
a person who drank tequila and then I
had like one of those nights in college
and then it was never again and I was
vodka vodka vodka and it really tough
for me because everyone around me only
drinks tequila and it would be on my own
bar tab you know what the clubs like
with my vodka shots and I was like super
sad and I knew that tequila was the
place to be but Peter cross wounds me
because a whatever but because you told
me was an upper and that it really helps
with just like keeping you energized and
I just have to say I haven't looked back
since
snitch also was on the bandwagon as well
and it has just been such a premium
experience and you've really elevated my
alcoholism so I have to just thank you
so much good very proud
the trousers will kill us if we don't
take some of their questions right yeah
so I'm gonna head over to Instagram also
where you guys can give this right now
so commit us - USA and then you can use
code it's Peter 20 then get 12 percent
discount right away
Peter 20 yeah I know honestly is great
stuff so I've been using it for a while
now and like the instant you start to
see or like a red dots or to appear I
started using it and gone or you can
like sometimes you don't see it but it
hurts that is the worst and I've used
everything like the old adage of using
toothpaste has a broke kid I used to
face had never worked I think it worse
and it smells weird yeah and then I'll
use like a couple oceans that are just
basically the counter and right it
always irritates my skin this
first thing I've ever use it doesn't I'm
taking all the twister questions to be
honest just a lot of people want you to
be the bachelor and would you ever
including it looks like is there any
shred of a chance do you ever see
yourself like being in a time in your
life where you would say yes I wouldn't
say I wouldn't say like a straight yes
or no right now I mean what's the
craziest DM you've ever received Crais
is DM or fan encounter there's a girl
who I think I've like a legitimate
stalker in another city where she writes
some I don't know her name you write
some a fake encounter at time every time
I post it and that's what I would do but
it's the same like yeah she writes some
very scary stuff go into detail because
it's actually like pretty oh she's a
lover or a hater like skyriver okay yeah
she thinks that oh like were lovers
right oh wow yeah it's Klaudia is
finding genuine genuine people to date
gotten more difficult since being on the
show I would say so yeah inevitably yeah
probably gets even harder after our show
extremely yeah there's like I remember
that one thing you said now people know
you like on a more friendly personal
level of who's 10 like they never
watched this and the right say something
that they well that's the thing yeah
like people already know about me for
Gardens right which is strange because
it's just a one-time show and I didn't
have any like talents or like specific
things going into the show that
pertained to me as a person and so
having someone know that much about me
or had that like level of celebrity has
been very odd it's like a vanity thing
like people thought you were hot so like
now they know you
yeah pretty much they like to get to
that's very weird don't think you read
out to a [ __ ] does anyone call you that
no what from just my mom
it's a Mean Girls all right just my mom
that's like when those jokes are you
saying someone else repeats it and they
get the laughs no I don't listen to
anything but the sound of my own voice
cuz I'm not used to people around me
being like funny but you're so someone
has to like like yeah it was funny
rewind it wasn't you
[Laughter]
if you could do anything differently in
the whole bachelor I'm sorry all these
questions people just love you on The
Bachelor your whole bachelor experience
which it was there anything you would
have done differently like picked up the
auction I would've done read more more
research on the show before going on so
I never watched the show before it was
more just encouraged upon me by friends
right and so when I went on I kind of
went blindly so are you referring to
like it being demanded of you to get
engaged yeah yeah but that was like kind
of a new ish thing like it wasn't always
I did it that way like Juan Pablo didn't
get engaged and I mean like once in a
while of like someone was normal it's
just like that dated someone that they
meant for - do you feel actually another
thing about it do you think there's any
competition between you and John booth
with your fitness okay we seem like very
different people I've never met him yeah
passing yeah I don't know much about him
I guess I don't think so America's the
fattest country in the world we need
more than one good I know he opened up a
gym gym as well but in Madison so what's
your gym called
that's gonna be Peter Krause madness of
course yeah yeah it's gonna be awesome
pkew I Peter I was we every cousin
Crosby it's very because it's extremely
misleading and we talk about it every
time here on the show but we have so
many listeners it's like please explain
the WI in your Instagram Wisconsin I'm
very proud Wisconsin it--and it's like
in my emails been Peter Krause at well
Peter Krause WI at hotmail.com since I
was there anyways would did like Claudia
O'Shea and why at gmail.com like we
wouldn't think it was Claudia ash Rainey
because it's content it's like ya know
it's like it's like Jay Jay my husband
Roger Mathews MJ Robbie Matt Robert
Roger Matthew SWAT is how I made it
you do yes I know sponges it's long
story
but what name is Crosby anyways that
one's well that's two cousins back to
back it's very hot it sounds weird
it's not that weird um another question
for you have you gone on even one date
with anyone from bachelor nation no but
if you had to I had to regardless if
they're like in a relationship or not
because I'm not the favorite something
like a teacher you should like he's a
bit he's a gym teacher
oh wait I did watch a couple episodes of
Jo Jo season I know he's very attractive
but I like it she and Jordan seem really
good yeah yeah they do seem really happy
Lulu I'm happy for let you know and so
who are you still close with from your
season I still got my best friends like
Dean Dean and Iggy I'll see actually
this weekend I'm going to LA I just
stopped a lot of it just all of it just
stopped like the whole thing was like I
like to everything just like stop that's
Chris Medina he's one of the most
talented and intelligent people I've
ever met like he does these simple
little things here and there that just
like give you a glimpse of his talent
and he doesn't follow it as much as I I
personally actually yeah I had no idea
he was talented he's got yeah so like
uses his drone all the time Eames very
good at just his short little videos
like we need some places there you go
bring your time I think you know loves
the west coast Oh unless you guys move
out there he's price day see miss
Christina I have no idea about his
dating life right now like in our little
group texts like all the guys so Alex
Dean myself Iggy
we just kind of shoot do you say curse
words like in your everyday life cuss is
probably too much like I said you're a
teacher like I feel like you don't know
but the teachers her curse outside of
school great knowing when and what not
you bro yeah yes
Texas where I get in trouble gosh like
if I'm saying something to a friend it's
in text I kind of forget like that's a
careful and someone could say jot
screenshots live forever memories last a
lifetime that many screenshots I'll be
my memory is very short so luckily
there's so much in common
oh my god no I have dementia well you
remember the important stuff no not in
that you remembered what I said last I
was here
well of course I would remember what my
true love that but like anyone else I
just I really can't remember like I
remember probably ten minutes of my
yeah like 18 do you remember like super
specific glimpses oh well I remember
like two days but once in fourth grade
when I told a really big lie and then
like another day like when I got my
period for the first time like that's
literally it traumatic experience
experience exactly and even so we have
to tell you got really upset about it so
just before you leave yes tell me that
beautiful you're very beautiful
okay everyone follow Peter Crosby on
Instagram to find out where they can get
because people don't want to get tickets
to boot camp take us we'll be up in the
next probably 12 hours at the most out
say oh my god and they can find the link
to committeth even though I'm
pronouncing it improperly coming this to
us USA doc yeah they'll probably find
this in my stories and then you can just
go to what Peter 20 20 percent off for
testers you guys we're always looking
you up it's exclusive to the chose to
only I don't really look where we're
looking everywhere everybody ciao guys
we can't think Peter crossed me enough
for coming on our show gracing us with
his presence make sure to leave a
comment on his Instagram being like
thank you so much Peter for just like
loving us as much as you do
thank you Peter first I know you have to
stay in for a longer next time we have
to guest co-host next time that'd be fun
yeah I'm gonna get sick feeling like you
just gonna trip in the street um thank
you Peter perhaps with your baby or make
sure to follow Peter Cosby on Instagram
Facebook snapchat and Twitter all the
good stuff and keeping up with Anne in
tune with what's going on in Peters life
we're gonna take a quick quick break
redo the set so hard we'll be back in
two minutes with the rest of the show
what she said toodles
you
we have returned back down to earth we
are calm
we are collected sort of I have so much
adrenaline like laughter because usually
our guests are at the end so it's like a
great way to end on a high but huh now
I'm high on drugs and I have to come
back down and do the show and we have to
like now get to work and we have so much
to discuss no no it's like the stuff
this is gonna be a six-hour show it's in
a six hour show we also like need to
discuss Peter like I have a meeting at
five o'clock so like we have so just
wrap it up okay no that's great now um
wow I can't believe Jackie oh no Mo was
this weekend no no I mean so let's just
having fun so much just have configured
Jackie O no mo what six years ago it
really does I was remembering stuff like
on the plane home because like we were
drinking so much like you okay I
remembered something like that we were
doing on the first night that was so
funny like the way you were saying
Jackie O no mo no mo Jackie no nobody's
the only way to say it can be like
Jackie or norm or oh my god it was so
funny like from the second we got there
it was just premium premium no he hit
the ground premium me hit the ground
[ __ ] it and you know I was so funny it's
like the first day we got there like
everyone came on different flights like
everyone got to the pool probably by
like 4 o'clock look we were just
planning on like taking a dip like
relaxing and then like getting ready for
our big night out and like and we just
like ordered shots to like celebrate
like because they're an imaginary party
and we like unintentionally got just
blackout right and so we like then got
ready blackout then just kept on being
so drunk
no literally the whole trip for me I
don't even remember anything but just
like seeing like brown not black because
I remember something like Brown no
honestly I remember just seeing colors
because the hotel was so colorful oh my
god we were so colorful I can't stop
telling everyone about the hotel because
I have to be honest I had no idea what
it was and everyone was like oh that's
like the cool hotel I'm like I hate the
cool hotels because the cool hotels are
always shitty and to me it's like you go
to the Bahamas there's one place to stay
the other one is it's like just it's
everything else and Atlantis and I mean
everything else is like the Atlantis
right and I was just being like a
trooper and I can't tell you like how in
love with the hotel I was and I keep
telling that I'm like we have to go
because the
and you were in a sleep-like we had a
standard room and it was like so nice
and I just like loved the hotel I didn't
know they had a casino when we were
going and it was just like there was a
million pools like it was just so
[ __ ] premium there were so many pools
it was so pretty yeah like everything
was just so well I went to a bathroom in
the lobby on the last day that I had
never walked into and I've never been in
a more beautiful bathroom my life I like
feeling dudes put in my story I'm like
that's weird wait was it by the ATM no
it was by the clio restaurant oh no not
by daytime another beautiful bath you
know that bathroom everything was just
like beauty and they cool the rooms the
bathroom doors were like Iridessa yeah
it was so cool it was just so well and
that's why our photos were so premium
hashtag giacomo the flow from the
weekend I mean which was important to me
in my new preset lifestyle and everyone
really delivered I am so like jealous of
the person I was on Friday night I want
to be her again
me too and my Instagram on caught my
personal Instagram account cloud within
a job you browse the Internet I broke
the internet got ok on Club with no job
I probably on average probably like 12
to 15,000 likes on like anime got really
premium photo 20 and then like for like
a huge celebration 30 like my engagement
or like my picture from your bet track
almost 40 that's great that's gonna get
on girl toe job that has three million
fault no it was so crazy it's funny
because before we went on the trip you
were saying how you're gonna just turn
into like a turbo thought oh my back was
all up some way with all the clothes you
were ordering order boohoo like trash
and now you know why Instagram thoughts
are like just so inspired to do what
they do because forty thousand likes
forty thousand likes oh no no I have to
show my Met Ball next time totally
that'll be on Olivia's back to me
totally
nobody was like first like that night
okay so for the first night we just
threw ourselves in what did we do even I
don't remember the first thing we went
to Katsuya oh oh my god the longest most
delicious dinner ever like there was so
much food and everything was so good I
was eating so much and I was like oh my
god they kept Embree in the picture of
us with me blowing out the candle there
are so many cups because they were
bringing the shots we all had like water
Diet Coke and a cocktail each right and
it was just like I brought my champagne
from the room then they brought us two
rounds of shots just cups it was just it
was I mean it was so much like I don't
remember anything no I and I felt like I
was the only one that's in her eating
because like everyone was just so busy
no actually I really didn't eat at that
dinner
that's enough for everyone the food was
so good all weekend every restaurant was
soaked and I loved to the Katsuya cuz it
was literally in the middle of the
casino so you were just like surrounded
by bright lights big titties right and
it was so great you left the restaurant
we're in the casino everyone's gambling
ivy I really didn't gamble at all this
trip it was just like I've never got on
the good table you know and I never I
don't want to make a big deal about it
but like just no one gave me their seat
I couldn't get I couldn't get ahead so I
don't want to talk about it okay so
let's move on because Emmy was a smart
thing where's like I gave Jackie money
for the trip like before
we gambled because I knew like I knew I
was gonna be less liquid and I was right
yeah
I'm Raven Symone less liquid a future
predicted future prediction what's worth
psychic future predict affair
clairvoyant then we went to the club and
it was like we walked out into the
resort like everything we never left
there were lunch which is which was my
goal wherever I went like I wanted it to
be all-inclusive like we eat during
party sleep laughs love there she went
to the club which was really really fun
and I realize like I'm just not a huge
club person so I was glad that wasn't
like a focal point of the trick it was
just like we were having so much fun is
like weird wheelies great music where do
we take all this energy it's like when
you leave America like the music that
they listen to from America is about two
years behind which is the best because
that's the best music right I don't want
to listen to today's hits I want to
listen to 2016 sets which is what we got
Barry Berman so I loved it and then we
went to the casino which is that night
is like we're like where I lost my cool
yeah
well half of us went to the casino every
night half went to the casino half when
swimming skinny dipper I was always in
the swimming I feel like I'd never
skinny dip before but as I burn I was
doing and I was like I've never had this
feeling of like oh my goodness machine
you gonna sue me if seen I mean as kids
everyone's getting tips cuz like you
don't have her house you don't have
parts right but it it was like such as
rails it was such a thrill I've never
done it oh my god you should have done
it at least once
well I was saying I forgot I was saying
this too but like if if anyone who works
at that hotel you very thank you to me
if anybody works at that hotel like
gathers together some security footage
from this weekend like my life is over
or your life like just begin I was very
like and I wouldn't do this everybody I
was like literally in the pool at like
clock we like we stayed at the pool
everyday like till the Sun went down
because that's the prettiest time of
death right no but we were there dark
like even yeah I was like I don't want
to be in my room while the sun's out and
I was just like and everyone was gone so
it was just like our group and like I
was just like flashing my titties like I
don't even do that I was like I was just
like doing it because like I don't know
a good party and it was dark and a
femine was like did like you guys
everything about getting a stripper for
the trip and it's like we don't need we
were the shooters gonna be the stripper
you just you know be the stripper you
wish your brain on your Bachelorette and
like remember that night that we went so
we've stayed at the pools till it got
dark out then there was like a kids pool
that has like all these caves that you
jump off of so we were doing it at night
like well at 8 o'clock and there was
still lifeguards so like we were safe
and drunk and we were just like going up
to the top of the cliffs and jumping off
which we never do stuff like we are not
cliff divers and it's just like fun
things to do sober and then when you're
drunk it's even more fun and better then
we did that the cliff dive the next day
sober and it was so [ __ ] scary he's
like I don't I wouldn't probably have
not have done it the sober day if I
hadn't done it the drunk day what's
crazy is we didn't even get around to
half the pools no and by the way we were
looking on the website like as we were
leaving and there were like six more
pools we think there were 9 pools total
and I think we only went to four of them
well the one that we went to that was
like the day party was so funny and so
fun and like honestly I made friends for
life friends for life it was something
that was just exactly what I wanted
because I didn't want like Vegas where
everyone's in the pool and it's like hot
and steamy I wanted to be like if you
want to chill you can chill I didn't
know and I said this before we left for
the trip I didn't know what my vibe was
gonna be and this hotel like let me make
my vibe if I if I actually wanted a
chill trip it would have been amazing of
course I did not want to children but
the last day that we were there was a
chill day he's like Sunday almost a
vacation yeah and it was like a
relaxation nation and it was still
wonderful like we didn't drink we just a
we went to every pool and every pool had
a different menu and we were like
cheering we're like new menu yeah one
had pizza one didn't know it was so
funny I ate so much every restaurant was
actually so good you know what I was
actually in the shower last night
thinking like oh I should weigh myself
tomorrow morning but then I was like no
definitely not cuz I was a beast but
then I was also like I don't think I ate
anything okay I didn't even remember
eating
oh I that's probably because I ate
everything before you could get to right
and I we stopped till like noon every
day I never do that yeah the beds were
so comfortable never alone and I slept
with snitch which was
like obviously not an ideal experience
like just sharing a bed but it was
totally fine oh that's great I had my
own room in my suite and like thank you
to everyone who allowed me to do that
like that was that's the things that are
important to me it was it was really
nice and but I've never been on about
surrett party before I've been on my own
bachelorette party was which was
extremely stressful um just because like
you're worried about like people can't
France cool friends yeah and then also
like mine was sponsored so there was
like a lot of work involved and I got in
trouble once so like I would try to pick
the whole time but yours was just like
laid back and I couldn't have used it
more like it was just I didn't realize
how much I needed it like how wound up
so tight I was and like I wasn't a
granny and you know I was thinking about
this last night like I've been going
nonstop like worth wise-4
since June so like for five months
straight like because June July August
September October like five months like
I literally have just not stopped and I
have a really big week this week and I
was just like I needed it yeah and it
was Emily got it it couldn't been at a
better time and it couldn't have been
it couldn't have exceeded my
expectations like anymore I'm obsessed
with the Bahamas in general like you
know the perfect distance like from New
York for a real true vacation with like
blue waters and you still are
technically leaving the country but you
do US Customs in the Bahamas so you know
when like customs is torturous anyway
but I think a lemon I'll have a
make-a-wish Gucci bag Gucci bag but you
better get your bag Hermes Jacque
haramain stuck
customs is gonna be torture regardless
but like landing in New York and then
like after all the treacherous travel
and then having to do customs is the
most is the least premium thing so it
was annoying like when we got to the
airport I to wait like another line just
to get my passport thing checked and
like take that picture in the machine
but then when I got to JFK
I just wants to a cab like it was so
[ __ ] premium it's as easy as
international travel can be the flight
was so easy and now with my new food
place and SL specifically like I can't
wait to go back there no I walked in the
door first of all the furniture was so
cute I was literally in the lobby
opening cabinets looking for tags of
where this like certain furniture was
from I couldn't find it it was really
annoying there was like this wet bar
that was so [ __ ] cute and I really
wanted to see where it's from I was
literally on my hands and knees
underneath having people like open it
looking for me I couldn't find it but
literally I walked in I texted Ben I'm
like we have to come back here Ben would
love like I want to come back as a
family as
only like a group place look III think
my next time we would go is like we need
to do a couples trip I'm so down
everyone there was and we were already
planning our net ship and it's like to
all bachelorette parties like they
already start talking about how they
have to do this every year honestly know
there were so many miserable
bachelorette parties oh my god there
were so many bachelorette parties going
on at the same time as s and it's like
people and the life that we live is
weird because like people stare and
probably 20% of the time they're staring
because they're toasters and they like
want to come hang but like 80 percent
it's because like we're being loud and
and we're like we're having the fun that
they wish they were having and they'll
stare in jealousy and it's not clear
which ones which so sometimes it's a
toaster but they're staring and
obviously staring rude and if you're a
fan come say hi and you're just like
what do you want stare you know it was
it was a bachelorette party but actually
wasn't a bachelorette because one of the
girls was pregnant so I think it was
like a bridal thing
Oh and they were they literally traveled
internationally to stare
they crossed international waters just
to stare and they were like at the pool
party like the party pool so it's like
you're in a pool party like you have a
table you have bottles you have food you
have friends and you're literally
sitting staring at us like twerking in
the pool like let us live it was and
they weren't staring and like if
someone's staring in a way where it's
like they want to take a picture like
you know I'll live like that's the life
I chose for myself but if you're staring
and you have no clue who I am and you're
just like a [ __ ] with your [ __ ]
cross-eyed Mulligan
[ __ ] off like they were just being so
scary like trying to make us feel like
we were being - we're like no working
[ __ ] we're having the best time also
there was a group of stairs who stared
all the way to the airport on the way
back we're going up the escalator
they're waiting for their friends to get
through global uh the customs and
they're literally staring at us on the
escalator I'm like and then finally they
look away if you ever encounter ass
terror all you have to say is this taken
from the words of Massie block what do
you want stare see what they say no I
really like I what I wish we had engaged
more at them but we were just so busy
having the best time and they were so
busy like focusing on other people like
on their vacation like you paint Brad to
stare very sad but now obviously like we
were talking about this last week like
from all the traveling that I've been
doing in the same pair of leggings like
I was very on high alert that I was
gonna get a UTI but like now that we
were literally running around the
Bahamas like in at the same day than
stood for four days like now I'm 100%
certain
that I'm gonna get a UTI and I didn't
order you Cora like now I'm like this is
the time
no bachelorettes should come with like
you know the little penis straws like a
sash and a package of Aurora that is
such a and it's pink so it's like
they're new and it's like you could
actually probably and this is probably
not recommended but you could put it in
your alcoholic beverage because it's
like a Pinot if you can it's like pink
lemonade flavored it's a mixer no and
I'm gonna what's me the code by the way
yeah the code is toast
tio ast texted two four eight four eight
four eight and they will send you the
code to use to get uh thirty percent off
oh [ __ ] I did I ordered the regular way
I got a cancel I gotta use the code of
course you do just text toast two four
eight four eight four eight is enough
get you Korra and say goodbye to UTIs
right now you Korra's offering thirty
percent off when you text toast two four
eight four eight four eight but hurry
this is a limited time offer text toast
two four eight four eight four eight to
get 30% off your order of you Cora
that's toast TOA st as seen right behind
this to get 30% of you Cora four eight
four eight four eight no I'm like really
nervous about it but I think I'll be
okay I think I'll be okay because
usually drinking like we made it a point
to shower every night oh my god I
showered did my hair and makeup black
out cuz this morning I was doing my
makeup and you know when like you and
just like you keep doing your makeup the
same and it's like becomes monotonous i
sat down I was like why why did my
makeup been so long I'm like wait noise
you don't remember I don't remember
doing it but I looked so beautiful every
night and like I was fine
maybe I should get more drunk more often
for sure you just a thought just there
was one probably the busiest day that
Saturday the day party and everything
and I managed to shower three times that
day what once in the morning once before
we went out that night and then once
before bed and then once before bed
because we were in the pools for an hour
and a half I was a prune prune season
I've never spent so much in my life
prune SID a prune and proven city [ __ ]
no Jackie doesn't swim like on vacations
like she's the girl who doesn't swim and
like I didn't even care about my hair
and there was one day but one night that
I did my hair that first night I mind up
wearing in a pony anyway then the second
day we were just like swimming all day I
was high bun season the rest of the trip
it was just so liberating and when you
have that bohemian glow with the
backdrop but there's nothing like SLS
Baha Mar what more do you need
there's a little preset season yeah no
we were mean so crazy
we're talking about how is brave season
because we're all out here oh my god
that was so funny so that's it Amy
Schumer joke which is a great segue oh
right okay I don't remember where she
said it but she's actually one of the
most true funny relatable things she's
ever when I saw her do stand-up she
opened her joke open her set with the
funniest joke of all time that also Dana
ruin because sharing in the joke and she
gave me the punchline oh she's so
annoying but I still enjoyed it
nonetheless she said so this year you
know I took some naked pictures like
some nude photos very tasteful and I
realized the worst thing you want to be
the worst word you want to hear when you
put out a naked photo brave no it's like
then that when you told me that I'm like
I totally not like people do you
especially because I'm on oh I just did
this is a great promotion for me too I
just in the diet starts tomorrow podcast
which is a batches podcast with two of
their co-founders and it's all just
about like feeling like like body cop
body positivity like just talking about
food like it's really like an open and
honest podcast and we did a great
episode and it got me thinking I was
like you're right like people died at me
and because I really feel like I exude
this confidence it's like very like it's
higher than it should be just like not
that higher than it should be higher
than anyone else in the world like
Giselle right I have more confidence
than Gisele Bundchen couldn't agree more
and people always like DME like I admire
your confidence like why is it so crazy
that someone should be confident if they
look like me like it's like I the
intention is obviously nice but that's
exactly what she's saying it's so it's
so funny so all weekend we were also
just being brave all weekend like really
posting just true pictures and bathing
suits like no time to even face - yeah I
posted like a mirror pic in an actual
bikini and it was brave season and we
were like we are the Atlanta Braves that
was so funny but that's a great segue
that's a great story first story of the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toes I feel like I'm
gonna keep coming back to the
Bachelorette Oh becoming a noble babe
oh so because we weren't on the same
plate like I never got a chance to talk
about it with you totally and I didn't
see you that morning right so like I
want to know how your trip was but she
did go to lunch you should do lunch free
actually you should really come over
after this and we should to go and
record a picture okay let's do that I'm
free okay and Theo
to do that your gift remember when I
told everyone I got her gift oh my god I
totally because I dementia forgot that
you I don't even remember you telling me
that you got me a gift but something
arrived yesterday and I get weird stuff
all the time yeah and I knew that and it
was so cute it was a throw pillow made
of sequins that was like a picture when
you push the sequins up it's a photo of
feel when you push them down and she was
a silver pillow I didn't know that yeah
I've been living them up because it's
pretended to make sure if the oh and it
was so funny and I was jacking called me
ship did you get my package and I'm like
and then I had like a big memory of you
telling me you got a gift but I couldn't
tell if I was just drunk so happy
housewarming I think it was very sweet
and it's on my couch and so I have to go
see it see the tags I mean I see the
couch and see the couch yeah Wow okay
first story Amy Schumer is pregnant
expecting a first child with her husband
Chris Fischer Amy Schumer is pregnant
reports enews the I feel pretty actress
is expecting her first child with
husband Chris Chris Fischer Schumer
shared the exciting baby baby news on
friend Jessica yellen's Instagram by
writing quote I'm pregnant a - Amy
Schumer on a list of her candidate
recommendations for voters for the
upcoming midterm elections Yellen
captioned the video on her story at a
mere Shamy Schumer getting out the boat
and something else so this is what I
didn't realize that's how she did it
yeah and so this is something I wanted
to talk about cuz I feel like this is a
good comparison because over the weekend
Elle magazine tweeted and an article
that said Kanye West and Kim Kardashian
are divorcing like breaking news and
when you clicked it it took you to voter
registration in your area and it was
quite controversial because while there
their intent was good like it's very
important to vote for sure
like is it nice to play with the
narrative of someone's life who like has
a family and it's like would they do
that to anyone but Kim no nobody has
respect for Kim that's what right and
Mosel my cell over and I saw that I'm
not gonna click the link I have the news
I need to know Kim and Kanye horsing so
I would never unknowing right and I
would just assume that to be the truth
that's so [ __ ] right at least this
she's using her own narrative so that's
what I was saying like this is the way
to do it like if you want to push voter
registration or certain candidates like
great this is your own storyline
do with it what you want like who is
Elle magazine to play with someone
else's life like Elle magazine really
wanted to like use clickbait to get
people to vote say Elle magazine is
going bankrupt I'll click right exactly
like Elle magazine socks destroy your
own life in pursuit of voter
registration not someone else and so
Kanye replied to someone's tweet because
some reporter was just like I feel like
this is wrong like if you're the type of
person who like can be tricked into
celebrity clickbait like should you even
be voting but like I was just like I
don't know why bothered me so much
because like at the end of the day like
they had good intentions like they just
want people to get registered I'm like
that's an important thing for sure don't
get me wrong but like the road to hell
is paved with good intentions
right and it's like not that people were
saying they compared it because like
they did the same thing when Pete and
Arianna broke up they did Peter Arianna
are broken up in the link took you to
voter registration but that was true
that's true right so it's not even the
same and I just feel like they wouldn't
have done this to anyone else and I feel
like it was like so mean and I don't
know why it like really bothers me no
that really bothers me and it likes
because it's the only Schumer for doing
it in a good way and on her own terms in
like using her own news to to first
write whatever it is exactly but that's
what your own news can do for you so el
news could take a page out of the girl
with the lower back tattoo for sure Amy
Schumer's book but maybe she was booked
it's cop the girl with the lower back
tattoo I can't believe she's pregnant
though like now thinking about the
actual news I feel like this is really
good for her because she honestly like
she needs new material okay because like
I've never seen her stand-up but you've
seen it I've actually seen her stand-up
specials her stand-up at MSG she did
stand-up at pier 17 that was like more
closer to her SNL monologue plus some
and it's like hurt her bit has always
been that she's like this single drunk
you know like loose woman which by the
way she's not even that she like once
said she's not even like that type of
she portrays like she's a person and
train wreck but then she's like I also
only had one one-night stand
oh so anyway so that was her bit but now
she's a married woman so like you can't
even make those jokes anymore really
without like disrespecting your man and
so now she'll have edenian show like
make motherhood jokes and I'm ready for
some like funny motherhood content right
it's like who's the funny mom comedian
right that's so true and I feel like
there's so much funny [ __ ] about like
your vision being ripped open but just
being a mom and like having a baby and
like all the like feelings associated
with it because it's like such a
wonderful thing but then you know there
there's Stephanie I love your kid but
like you also hate it right and that's
like only Miranda from second city she's
only present honest enough to have said
that right so hopefully Amy Schumer well
like be honest be on
with us so I'm ready for it me too um I
had a thought because it's just I find
that like I think Amy Schumer's like
trajectory has been so weird because I
feel like she was like it like for like
there were two years where like it was
Amy Schumer's world and we were just
living in it
and when we posted our Instagram that
her and Chris Fisher are pregnant the
comments were wild like- so much say and
it's like for the toasters who like are
a relatively respectful group like even
when they hate people if it's a woman
they like don't say negative things like
about their parents like for the most
part the toasters are like really
respectful even about people they don't
like they have like well-thought-out
arguments it's like why Busy Philipps
shouldn't have a show like you know what
I mean but the comments I had to delete
something like they were so mean and I
feel like they were coming maybe from
people who don't follow us but people
have turned on you mer I'm of two minds
cuz I love her so much I'm when she was
it it was like I was one of those people
who got her there because I supported
her so much you made me watch this video
I literally remember in high school like
literally sitting on our dining room
table and you making me watch this thing
about the bathroom attendants at clubs
do you know what I'm talking about it
was like this bit that you made me watch
a hundred oh that's so funny yeah cuz
she said inside Amy Schumer and I
honestly thing and I trainwreck was an
amazing movie and like it really may not
have voted her to like a level because
no one makes movies like that and
because she started it and wrote it and
like literally developed the whole thing
it was like so impressive and I know not
everyone loved it but I think I feel
pretty was like a more important movie
and it was the greatest movie of our
generation agree but don't forget that
in between those two movies snatched
happened which was not a good film
snatch happen yeah snitch snitch got
snatched snitch got snatched so I feel
like it's almost like they gave her like
too much like responsibility like so
soon but then also she really was out
there hustling for so long but
personally what I think like Amy Schumer
should do is bring back inside Amy
Schumer because I couldn't agree more
it's like the message that this were all
needs it's the like the way that the
content was packaged so it's like a show
on TV but then II there were all these
little segments that would go viral like
yeah it was like just meant for the
digital era and I feel like she just
could do so much more with it and it
ended too soon because she got too big
for TV she has they so choose telling
she's
one movie in America you don't need to
be on Comedy Central yeah but like I
feel ooh did it just get darker but I
don't think that changes our lights I
don't know I don't I don't care a little
dim lighting hello hello so I shall eat
some mood lighting I could bring back
inside Amy Schumer and I feel like it
would be a good start
yeah I don't know I don't know what it I
don't know what happened but ever since
like but that's what we do with everyone
as it looks like we'd love so much so
much happen with Tiffany Haddish I mean
night school I know but it's fine I
still love her so much I need you I
would see her do stand-up does she just
turned up it's like hard to tell the
difference between like a comedian and
like someone is funny I mean yeah but I
feel like she definitely did I think you
know I'm sure people feel it but now
you're true coming true but no no I I
don't know why we were bleeding the past
maybe two months I've been thinking a
lot about Amy Schumer in her career
maybe because like I see myself like
wanting to be like her but I'm just I
become obsessed with her like not in a
good or a bad way just like watching her
trajectory yeah but people think it's
interesting it's it's been but she's
still like up here and she's like
permanent Haley and she talks about in
her new her latest stand-up was like
more so bad house she's rich and famous
now and how that's changed her life and
it's really funny that is funny that
seems on and I look forward to you
getting to that level soon and making
those jokes I don't know why I'm just
like um I'm following her closely now
okay we'll follow this story closely to
also then her just getting married one
day after she was like dating what
seemed like the perfect guy for her
designer Ben Hamish like seemed like he
was so there for her they break up
very sad a month later she's married to
her friends she marry to her publicist
who literally like her publicist made
her like and everyone in industry talks
about it like she's like a
world-renowned publicist to only takes
on like a couple clients and the
publicist like really did a lot for her
and she did it her publicist was dating
this guy Chris for like years and Aimee
like obviously jokingly liked him and
then like they broke up in a year later
like home we're all with him and the
publicist was not invited and they no
longer work together that's crazy that's
weird
yes so like those things but like
there's so many things I also really
like about Amy Schumer like I like how
much like her and her sister are like
the best relationship and like she does
everything versus turned her sister does
everything for her and it's like I'd
love to watch that because your peers
and annoy me about her like her dad was
in the audience yes
at her show up here 17 and oh my god in
Bridget Everett like who closes her show
like motor [ __ ] love motor motor his
face and it was so funny that's so and I
think he might do it like at every show
that he's at right which is just a treat
you know there's so many things that I
really like about her she's just like a
home girl from New York right
G what Chuck Schumer of it all like how
can you not love it but some things just
bother me about her I don't know I can't
I haven't made the decision on Amy
Schumer had I I really I always liked
her cuz of how much I once liked her
like you know what he what like loved
her and if you like I'd literally would
have not known about her up until like a
year ago if it wasn't for you your well
maybe two years ago since straight but
it's and I feel like for a while I was
like mulling but then I feel pretty like
brought me back no no I feel pretty and
it's so funny because not to shade on
our sister Margot but I saw the movie
with Margot oh that is the part that I
had to I hadn't seen yes when we got out
of the movie now we have like a Margo
but he likes so unfazed by it and she
was like it was fine like whatever
where's like I got out of the movie and
like even though some parts of the movie
like we're all those stupid the message
was so good and so important and it was
living in my life like the movie was
being like I literally think she went to
my brain and took it out of my head cuz
like and this is what the literal but I
was saying on the tide starts my podcast
like all that confidence how it's
literally like confidence is a social
contract stealing words from the man at
this the gambling table like and I just
loved the movie and Margo was just like
man and it's like of course Margo's may
about it like Margo homegirl was born
confident with her blue eyes and her big
ass and her skinny waist and her big
tits that stand up on their own like
she's never known what it's like and I
just like this Amy Schumer movie was
like so good and so important and like
for that she will always in my book be
an A+ I agree it's just it's too
important of a movie you are how you
feel and I've been thinking about this a
lot and I've been like weary about
saying it on the show but I would love
to hear your opinion on it and I've
fully four it's very rare that I form an
opinion and talk about it I usually like
talk through my opinion and like end up
sayings and upsetting people but I've
been a police out there my opinion and I
would love to hear your thoughts on it
because people are now like taking
umbrage with the word skinny mm-hmm and
they're saying like if you if you call
someone skinny it's like an insult or
like saying someone is too skinny like
and that's just as bad as calling
someone fat and I would just love to
hear what your thoughts are on it
because I've naturally formed an opinion
it's hard for me to to relate to that
because I've only ever like I've never
been called just kidding no I've never
been called too skinny and it's like
I've never been in a point like if I
just forgot about what I looked I can
just eat what I want I wouldn't become
too skinny like I would become like I
don't understand I like and I know that
it's possible that people are too skinny
and they need to mentally but it's like
that is so far from my experience and
the people around me like our family
like we have like fast struggles
genetics like in running through our
veins so I don't really understand it's
like my dream is to be called you skinny
but I wonder if I ask any person whose
dream is to be called too fat but see
okay great point and I realized I made
my point this morning yesterday in the
shower it was a very busy shower for me
and here's the thing people who say like
being called skinny is the same as being
called fat I've never been called fat
because and here's my point my here's my
proof that it's way worse to be called
fat I mean it is but like I have to
prove myself to the world I add
something to that not only never been
called fat have never been treated fat
so the way that we treat fat people is
like the last frontier of like
discriminating against people in some
way that it's you think it's okay no one
discriminates or like treats you
differently that discriminates the wrong
road no one treats you differently
things for being too skinny but you
people who are overweight lacks one
point get treated differently and get
looked at differently I don't anymore
and and here's my final point even
though you just made a better point than
my final point but thank you here's the
thing here is why being called too
skinny will never be the same as being
called to fat because being called
skinny in this day and age is also a
compliment right being called fat for
whatever way you look at it is never
gonna be a compliment and it never has
been and never will be so like I
definitely create like calling someone
too skinny
it's controversial but please don't say
it's the same as being called to that
like I just I I feel like I've I let the
world to make up their weird rules and I
go along with it but this one I'm
stopping it is not the same it's not the
same thing as a person who like
definitely struggles to gain weight and
being called to skinny like I'm sure
it's hurtful but it's not the same as
being called that yeah and no one is
gonna treat you any differently for
looking too skinny
but you you're never gonna lose a job or
like not get the audition because you
were too skinny for the role but you
will probably lose a job or not get
part that you wanted in the play because
you were bigger sorry oh no yeah yeah I
don't know I've just been think about
that a lot because I wanted to form an
opinion on it cuz I feel like people do
look to me when it comes to the word fat
which I'm honored honestly and I feel
like it's like if you want to be
body-positive you have to be like an
equal it's equal for everyone and I'm
sorry it's not and I've now I'm now
brave enough it's brave season I'm brave
enough to say being Colts getting it's
not the same as being called fat and I
will take that to my grave it's free
it's easy but that's a good
controversial thing to say now so yes
I'm sorry it's not so I'm gonna point
the comments it's not I'm speaking of
getting a job or not getting one next up
Weinstein's Harvey Weinstein's casting
couch could end up on a shooting range
can't think of anything more perfect
Harvey Weinstein's infamous casting
Catholics actually actual couch could
wind up riddled with bullets real estate
broker Michael Rutter of Rutter Property
Group said Monday that a client is
considering white buying wine scenes
former Tribeca office which the post has
revealed still holds his three seater
sofa definitely nobody wants the couch
the circumstance in circumstances
surrounding it make people uncomfortable
if we buy it we'll donate the couch to a
shooting range
Weinstein left his cream-colored couch
behind who makes it when the Weinstein
comat moved out of 375 Greenwich Street
I made last year's torn of sexual
misconduct allegations against him I
don't know who makes it but I need to
know what that's it let me see very
scary and it's like wow he I know the
casting couch is a real sleepy but it's
like I didn't realize he had an actual
couch I thought it was like he's casting
hotel room right no it's like it's
there's not one couch not gonna limit
yourself to just being in New York right
but I guess like this was the couch
right the New York couch but I thought
he lived in LA folks like me most of the
time I don't know maybe there's an LA
couch too but thank you Shiva library
and what I think of a better resting
place for it no they should have they
should do so many things honestly they
should give it to us because we would do
so many things with it like I would
literally leave it in the middle
okay here's whatever channel you know
where the tickets booth is in Times
Square mm-hmm so I would leave it there
and I would bring like five or ten of
New York's finest homeless people to pee
on it and just like actually know what
I've done myself you know I would take a
dump on it I would have Chipotle
no users and leave it in the busiest
intersection in New York and New Yorkers
will plow through it and give it a day
that thing is
droid but I feel like it also should be
like bring it to rumble lets punch it
out wait look where the towels
housewives went and smashed glasses when
you're angry like take your anger out on
this couch wow there's so much we can do
with it but I think a shooting range is
a wonderful place for together or it
should be like a therapeutic exercise
for any victim of sexual assault like
you should if you've ever had an
experience that you need like help
dealing with the trauma you should be
able to take a [ __ ] baseball bat in
like a glass box and just like scream at
the top of your lungs and just beat it
up that's a good you also like need a
place in New York City for something
like that like you you really can't
scream in this city without alarming and
like there's no we're just swearing that
is so true I think about that all the
time you know what it's a problem
because when people do scream even if
it's like completely even if it's like a
funny scream like they're laughing the
sound of a scream in New York like
literally sends chills down my spine I
don't never ever ever ever ever forget
being in the basement library at NYU in
the computer lab like printing something
before class and hearing from one floor
up that scream of a lifetime like it was
a shriek it was from a murder movie it
sent chills up and down my spine the
whole library went silent
that's so scary and then nothing
happened like it was so scary everyone
went back to like just living after like
being quiet for ten minutes
I ran the [ __ ] out of the library like a
scream and when I when I see someone
scream and it's just like a girl and
it's like but it's like a scream that
like I look at you I'm like it she's
just scream it's like you know let us go
we're not allowed to scream you're not
allowed to point and you're being so
Sarma yeah
but especially in New York like we were
watching I was watching Riverdale isaq
before I went on Jackie O no mouth and
it was really like something in the
episode it happens that's really scary
and I scream Jackie I watched that on
the plane and I was in my seat Riverdale
I had to catch up but I'm black thing
happened I literally was in I was in my
tiny little scene like I screamed so
loud and I never scream like it was so
scary and it was 1 a.m. like in our
apartment and TAC was like you can't
scream like that because the neighbors
will hear and they'll think like so yeah
and and you should and it used to be
that you could scream in a movie theater
like during a horror movie no you can
because terrible things happen in movie
theaters now if you scream I am nuts oh
I can't go to the movies anymore like
there was a man and when I saw star is
born' he came to my aisle and like went
down to the end and like looked
underneath the chair
I was like oh is your gun under there
like what's under there and then he like
left and I couldn't something you mad at
the whole time remember we left a boo
baby because literally scary smacking
them no and you know what changed
actually there was a while where I just
wouldn't see movies cuz it was it was so
much anxiety like thinking about who's
around me and like what could happen
that it's not enjoyable and I'll grab
I'd rather just see it on demand like I
remember Margaret I went to go see pitch
perfect we watch the opening scene she
throws up and there was this guy who
came in like late he was just acting
like so weird and I felt so strange we
just left I was like this is it we're
hit but you know what changed going to
movies for me I pick because it's like
if you're a there's around there's
weight and if you're gonna do something
crazy or not going in the most expensive
movie in town yeah so like now I can see
movies like no honestly I'm here for the
prices of movie tickets going up because
that means like people are less likely
to do bad things there totally like it's
a more exclusive experience and like you
wouldn't choose that theatre literally
only when a man like I'm a woman can be
actually suspicious and I'm like no it
was it's that's okay I always forget
about that that there was a time where I
just didn't go to the movies because it
was like way too anxiety-inducing you
just you have there's so much trust you
Lucy don't they say something so much
trust you have to instill in your hell a
man I think about all the time to trust
we trusted each other so much like I
trust everyone who gets in a car like
every person who is a cab driver a bus
driver has a car to just not run me over
right like thanks honestly thank you
that's why you go like this we cross the
street yeah
like thank you for not killing me like
the fact that like that's what
civilization is like us just like
trusting each other not to like kill
each other yeah but these days to follow
this code of law but these days no one
respects the law or the trust and there
isn't a law like it's so crazy
okay next story ariana grande shares a
sweet video of Mac Miller oh my god it
was a saddest thing ever and her grandma
as ariana grande's tumultuous year
continues she's choosing to look back on
the good times the sweet nurse singer 25
shared an old video on her Instagram
story of ex-boyfriend
Mac Miller getting dressed for the
Oscars alongside Grande's mom Joan and
her grandmother Nona in the video Miller
who died in an apparent drug overdose
nearly two months ago has his tuxedo
jacket sleeve fixed while watching an
Elton John interview on TV quote I
should have worn that for the night
Miller says referencing the iconic
singer this statement ensemble unaware
that grande was recording the moment
Miller turns to her and starts to laugh
once he realizes
it's like such a cute sweet video and I
love so many things about Ariana but I
really love like the love she has for
her grandmother and her family and she's
very family-oriented gal and I didn't
know much about her and Mac Miller when
they were dating and I always thought it
was like her that she was dating someone
who was obviously like subpar to who she
was but like now the more obviously like
it's being like romanticized now that
it's like this this tragic ending but
like now I'm like I feel like I missed
out on the greatest love story of our
time yes but then remember when Mac was
still alive and people like she released
a song her master's in the road yeah
about her and she was like not
everything is what it seems like you
can't save someone
so yes it's easy to romanticize it in
hindsight of course and like that it's
kind of the effect that death has like
everything negative sort of washes away
as it should um but it's just I can't
even imagine like how difficult it is to
like think about I know that for her and
I feel like her time with Pete was like
you know when you're like drunk and urug
on a high and then you would come down
like you realize the consequences I feel
like now it's like the dust is settled
and it's like she can't look it's like
the one thing death is like the one
thing that can't be undone mm-hmm so
it's like what now but she looks like
fine also she was gonna go into social
media break then she's not and she's
like shopping and like I have some
sources and they say that she's doing
really fine and like she's she's okay
which is all we can hope for because
she's like a tough cookie now like life
has conditioned her to be a tough [ __ ]
and now it's coming in handy
yeah you know you go through something
so traumatic one time and it makes
everything else seem simpler yeah so
she's equipped she's equipped and I mean
she did have to unfollow five hundred
people on Instagram include 600 people
on Instagram last night including Ben
and Ben I was more upset about it than
Ben and Ben so smart he's like no it's
okay cuz like I already I'm turned she
answered it's like our GM's are forever
open it seems like he said he's okay
with it but she it's not like you know
it would've felt better if she unfollow
it would've felt worse if she had
followed like three people or even just
one horse so it's like you know at 600
like he'll live
hey she couldn't deal with the noise and
it was like a low on Instagram for Ben
but it was an extreme high for me on
Instagram last night because I got a Z
and from without her and she told me
that I'm gorgeous and she's loves
following me on Instagram nothing like
having
Gweneth Paltrow tell your gorgeous no
nothing like having Country Strong tell
you you're gorgeous
what's her name Kelly Nov grant at the
same Country Strong
cuz I'm country strong hard to break
like the ground you may Kelly canter
Thank You canter okay next story a
little business Walmart and Target a
little up that is your Jackie O no mo
voice that's young now mom no but it
wasn't the way I just Jackie was like
you know what he's like Jackie oh no no
like this yeah um and I just want to
clear something up because yes I'm
Jackie I'm no mo because I'm gonna get
married at my last name is gonna change
but I will always be Jackie O like
professionally toast why I was taking
some bridge with the other where you
were gonna get a pass hug you works is
I'm so excited to be like oh no mo but
that it's like oh it can't wait to get
away from my family no but it's like
when your glass my oh is so pertinent to
I am and that will tell me it worked
so technically be changing but it will
no I won't be changing my Instagram
handle or anything like that so I will
always be Jackie O professionally it's
my stage name um but I'm Tachyon oh wow
right like you know at your dinner
parties you're gonna be Jackie but I
when I'm on the PTA right Jackie wine
rub Jacqueline wine cortisone I think
you should actually go with Jacqueline
or a Jackie Lynn Jacqueline Jacqueline
wine rub next up Walmart and Target try
to sell better cheap wine Walmart Kroger
and target are rolling out premium wines
for cheap well if it's premium you know
where they're right there trying to copy
trader joe's success with two-buck Chuck
and capitalize on America's love affair
with wine very smart the big-box players
have recently tried a variety of tactics
new brands partnerships and delivery
choices to prove their wine bona fides
and attract the growing number of
Americans replacing beer with wines and
spirits in May Walmart introduced ten
private label wines for $11 a bottle the
line winemaker selection featured roses
and binos from Italy France and
California nicole simpson not to be
confused with nicole brown simpson
totally walmart senior wine a buyer it's
a tough name yeah but it's Nicole's what
a job and I see H o le isn't a show she
probably changed it like after
went down wait that's an amazing job
what it says I've had Walmart's senior
wine buyer the dream we need to put a
Livi up for the job totally
that's the job for Olivia completely
sorry Nicole you're out of a job yeah
told USA Today that they drew that they
quote drink like $30 to $40 bottles wine
maker selection is part of Walmart's
attempt to upscale its brands in stores
and online
the label is targeted at middle income
shoppers thinking about spending on a
bottle of vino the design doesn't bear
Walmart's logo making it more acceptable
to wine connoisseurs who want to trade
down all of this makes a lot of sense
very in tune with what's necessary and I
feel like people are always looking to
Walmart to like are they gonna change
with the times like are they gonna make
it is it [ __ ] PC Richards right and
they're really they're really trying to
be in tune with what's necessary and I
want to support them in this endeavor
yeah and knowing not to put the name
Walmart on a wine model is thank you for
being in tune because when I think
Walmart
I think toothless hillbilly I do but
here's the thing the thing is with wine
it's like I'm really left out of these
conversations because like I don't [ __ ]
with wine at all and I feel like as a
woman and as like an influencer like
that it's like it takes credit away for
me but I just don't [ __ ] with wine
anytime I drink it I get a headache and
I really never I'm never gonna drink red
wine cuz a I'm like too much of a Susan
Mayer too to be able to drink wine like
I'll get it all over me it's disgusting
and like I like I can stand rose' and
white wine but like if I'm drinking I'm
here to get drunk I'm here for a good
time not a long time but if I'm not
drinking I don't need like a light
buzzer like a woo like wine I'll drink
the diet coke you know yeah that's like
all or nothing for me that's where I'm
at now I might just like the nothing
aspect of it but I do love a good I love
a good white wine I don't know any red
wine like we did anyone in the dead of
winter snow storm season I'm drinking
white wine
yeah you just Ramona Singer like that
you just can't fight who you are no
that's the thing you can't change a man
that actually would buy wine from
Walmart like if New York City allowed
Walmart to exist here I know and I just
know now that there's a target now 114th
and first did you know that I knew that
there was a Target summer in the city
that is just out of my way no so they
opened a target in the city in downtown
and it's like this cool like boutique
and they sell like [ __ ] earrings made
by who what where and it's like that's
not what I need to do every time I go to
talk
I went down there and I was wholly
disappointed because it didn't try
background I went all this way for
[ __ ] hoop earrings from who well
we're like I wear hoop nation on 14th
and 1st like 1st Street for chugging
Avenue I'm saying so that was the first
one now I've heard they opened a real
tart
Oh like a [ __ ] supermarket like a
real one on 14th and first that's what
I've heard from Olivia but I haven't
been so I'm willing to take a trip but I
gave I gave target downtown my heart and
they stepped all over it that's not cool
no so let's enjoy your new wines at
Walmart like I'll only drink wine if I'm
like dying like need to get [ __ ] up
and there's nothing else around yeah
like it's not horrible but it's funny
that you like champagne when it has like
a very similar I don't like I don't love
champagne but like I love the ambiance
and like the environment where one
should be drinking champagne like
celebrate what did you enjoy yeah I
totally agree
ok our next story is very interesting
it's more it's less of a story and it's
more of a report a new collaborative
consumer insights report that is taking
measurements of the biggest brands black
really was a slow news day no no it's so
interesting ok the top brands websites
platforms restaurants that teens met gen
Z populates ok now to find Gen Z for me
it's in exact terms ok um I can't I
don't know if I can give you exact model
use I want to know like what exactly is
Gen Z where does Gen Z stop and
millennial start you know no they
defined as people born from the mid
1990s to the early 2000s you just miss
gen Z what a night mid 1990s was 99 and
I've okay I'm Jen Z no you're not your
brother that makes me feel really I
thought I was like way aged out of Gen Z
you're from one year off Gen Z I'm
really am a gens II animal any land I
feel like I am in my soul but I always
thought like I still to you because also
Millennials are also 34 so we're on the
tail end of millennial and I'm just
gonna hop on over to the gens e train I
am Mandy Moore in a watch remember I
have one leg on Gen Z and one leg on
Millennials and I'm in two places at
once you're you're in two generations at
once yeah but so they surveyed 8600
teens the average age at being fifteen
point nine so maybe it's not us in 47 US
states and this is what they found out
okay
the top clothing brands that they wear
one Nike to American Eagle three adidas
for forever21 five PacSun I was gonna
guess forever 21 is the first one top
beauty destiny wait let me guess beauty
destination is in like brands no um
stores to buy beauty products Ulta
number two Sephora number one I'm like
so over Sephora um I mean I just love
the happiness no it's like if I need
something and I'm walking by it like out
of convenience I'll go but if I'm going
to browse for new makeup I will only go
to Ulta because I can't afford so they
also had top cosmetic brands oh and it's
not what you would think you want to
hear no I don't know one tart oh I
believe that too Too Faced three Mac for
Maybelline five Anasazi Beverly Hills
that's expensive things too I don't [ __ ]
with Too Faced at all because I have a
problem with them why they really became
like a popular brand there a cheetah
brand benefit benefit cosmetics was like
so pop in and they had the cute like
old-school feminine like high-waisted
underwear like the 50s right it is glam
and then Too Faced came out literally
making it products that looked identical
so people like accidentally bought
two-faced thinking it was benefit
because their logo was the same their
font was the same and like now they're
more successful than benefit they got
bought out by Estee Lauder interesting
and it's like that's annoying to me
because they literally stole someone's
ideas I agree and they count like so
much pay for and they got better they
did then they did it better
top handbag brands Michael Kors number
one number two
Louis Vuitton that's number four number
two's Kate Spade number three is coach
or lv5 could you bag Gucci baggage of
bad that's so interesting how was a 15
year old affording a Gucci bag I mean
their parent it's an average household
income of sixty eight thousand dollars
it's getting a Gucci bag for their 15
year old Wow I need to become a fifteen
point nine year old I need to become a
teen okay no that was very high tatted
fake you do need you just never know so
I put that much effort I don't know
exact offi it seems that you along the
show it seems like you wanted to happen
you start it and then you like really
needed to give you your effort so I can
make it believable well you don't know
me no I don't obviously DLE video
consent
where do they watch the videos the mouse
is this like platform or device platform
YouTube one is Netflix oh right two is
YouTube three is cable 4 is Hulu and
then 5 is other but it's so crazy that
there's two digital services that come
before TV very crazy and I'd say that
gives our little web show some hope top
restaurants for the chains yeah what do
you think number one is and this is for
both Chipola upper income teens and
average income teens have the same
number one and it's at mcdonald's now
what is it
chick-fil-a oh that makes sense and they
both have the same number two which is
starve out this is just so interesting
because it's really like national where
it's like we live in our own bubble and
there's like one chick-fil-a in New York
and chick-fil-a is not a thing here like
no black people you go line up around
the block for that chick-fil-a but it's
not a part of like culture like in
Atlanta it's like a part of your
everyday life so that doesn't surprise
me but it wasn't top of mind for me
because it's really not in New York that
McDonald's is number four Chipotle's
number three Dunkin Donuts is number
five it was number two
Starbucks oh okay yeah that makes sense
just it's just as important here as it
is in you know Louisiana yes and
favorite social media platforms one is
snapchat Wow oh is Instagram by the way
I've been getting a couple dm's like
what happened to your snapchat and it's
like I made it very clear I was
migrating over but like should I start
no I can't my habits I don't think teens
are storing and watching your videos on
sunshine I think they're really trying
to get to each other and they're
shrieking yeah they're streaking Margo
to streak yeah a little but like some of
my friends like streak heavy but what's
the most you've ever streaked
I got up to like 90 something 1 no
that's not right yeah that's how they
get ups like 4 or 500 and snap has like
a bug where it's like it's getting rid
of people's streaks when they're not
breaking it themselves
and they literally have a forum where
you can submit like hey I was up to 200
68 and we didn't we didn't break it but
you guys said can you restart it and
they'll go give it back to you is so
stupid you have to some people like
Jewish people they can't snapchat on
holiday so they email they're like hey
it was yun t'v and i couldn't do it and
they get their thing back oh my god the
Jews are like so out of control
sometimes like that it's not a no
getting to him that's not like a
could use some buy anything you're the
Jewish star yeah the Jewish card and use
it Jewish cards like miss class not turn
your [ __ ] snapchat streak I guess if
you're a 15.9 you do so dumb that's
crazy
what a world it's just me interesting
are you glad I chose that over yeah I
know I am and now I feel like maybe I'm
really not a Jen's e'er I feel like and
so I don't know what I am I think I'm
just smiling when it comes to like
kissing but to all the boys I loved
before like I very much identified with
the young adult generation but then with
like platforms I'm very Gemma lineal and
you do still have cable yes but I really
like maybe you're a baby boo
no I really feel like on my device it
actually depends just cuz Hulu is the
one that has a Netflix but I mean it's
one that it's Desperate Housewives but
like I really feel like my priorities
are Netflix Amazon Prime cable no but
like thing about Bravo yeah
Bravo's got to figure it out because I
would cut cable if it wasn't for Bravo
you go back to everything on the Bravo
app live but you can't record it no and
you need someone's cable login to watch
it live right right that's the thing
it's like all these apps have the
ability to watch live if you have a
cable log right it's gonna become like
Netflix where one person in every family
pays for cable and everyone uses the log
n that's very like I'm all got kicked
off because XP rose Olivia's fiance is
the only one that has Hulu and we're all
using it like Larry because we all know
Jackie started me watching that started
I got you you got mom like now we all
got kicked off because we're all using
one [ __ ] Hulu I'm not using say I'm
using uh sax brother well now it started
to use Liz Heights so who's a toaster
who maybe tell you about this oh you
know it Lexie love it she's so nice she
let me make my own profile so I started
watching ok wait guys I started watching
on Liz Heights and they didn't want to
use Elizabeth's so I went down to like
the last profile obviously the person
who was like least significant it was a
scrolling Madison and I have a feeling
Madison is six years old because she was
watching dragon dash'd and it's like
drinking dragon Josh honestly good
content premium on both ends yes of the
spectra I mean too much friggin Josh Wow
I can't believe we got everything we
needed to get through those were the
Fast Five stories are you here tomorrow
yes okay that's good so we have like
more time to like hang out yeah we have
to go stirs tomorrow did I do it then no
okay he gives the worst advice so like
with him once and he was just like
disagreeing with me for the sake of
being a contrarian like that's fun yeah
but like we're giving out real life
advice here these are people's lives
yes so we'll do that tomorrow so email
do toasters at gmail.com if you have
anything you want to get off your chest
it's all anonymous we're taking advice
about dating relationships friends
family but we really like the more
interesting ones like should I let my
boyfriend donate to a sperm bank you
know things like that right Oh so um
tell us movie of the week I know I
haven't watched it yet and honestly like
I need to put trust maybe on the week of
the week on hold for about two months
okay okay it's given like the shows and
then our trip like I I just can't take
that on right now and I want to do what
I can do to the fullest extent not take
on more than I can handle and do it all
half-assed I totally agree
so I'm putting just movie of the week
officially on hold because it's too
disorganized and like we just I would
rather like dole out the past 5 good
advice and like we got 10 yeah I
understand
also patreon members we have all five
episodes coming for you well we have one
already but the rest of the week you
will get all of your premium content
it's gonna be amazing we have some
really fun videos and cute things from
the Bachelorette we share with you guys
like the newlywed game do we record the
Overeem estates end video that's gonna
um and we're gonna do an episode today
we're gonna do an episode with libyans
at my home tour is still happening yeah
we're a little behind this month but you
will get you look at everything by
October 31st as promised and make sure
to head to pee because if you don't
it'll be very smooth I think remember
what I suggested
no you probably don't know but I think
that's what we should do and I'll remind
you but I think I'll be really easy and
like really funny okay okay I don't know
how to as funny as last year it's like
that's what I'm annoyed that like our
first year and Halloween was like so I
mean think because it'll never be that
good no but I think I have something
really good if we act as those people
the whole time it'll be really funny
okay anyways thank you all so much cool
show I have one more announcement sorry
some self parotia I you know I can make
some announcements too so I'm gonna be
I'm leaving for Boston tomorrow after
our show and I'm spending the night
because I just wanted like really
relaxed come to the Boston vibe like
walk around it's the World Series so
like the hotel rooms are $800 and I a
World Series is in Boston yes what or
know it's like the playoffs something
that it's like it's like a big deal and
I booked my hotel like literally months
ago when I booked the show before they
knew if the tea
was gonna be there so it's good but
obviously a forgot to book snitches one
and literally homegirl was trying to
charge me a $10 a night for the hotel
but we worked it out it's like it's so
crazy but so basically for each show I
asked in advance I wanted like 20
tickets like for myself for like my
friends and family and they didn't end
up needing all them so I'm going to
release them I've released them slowly
but surely but I want to make sure that
the people that go at them are like the
boss Dean's like not like random people
like I want it to be like the people who
really want it if you're watching right
now where can you get the ticket just
stay tuned on my Instagram stories
because I'm putting it up and they're
gonna be gone in like a second so I'm
gonna take it down right after so like
try and just be on the instagram story
if there's like literally 15 tickets
left and I just want to make sure like
it's not about money I just want like
the people to come understand um
oh my god we didn't talk about Cleveland
Oh how was it okay should I be packing
my bags honestly yeah like it was way
Premium me and my row stayed at the
Metropolitan which was like a super nice
hotel and Chris Chandler they say stays
there when she goes to have sex with
Tristan and it was it was literally like
such a nice hotel
it was very City vibe without the
traffic even though they did have
traffic but it's not even comparable to
it's not even and this show was good
it's like I feel like I should talk
about it cuz like I feel like people
don't know when they when they come to
my show like what's gonna happen and I
feel like I was like I didn't know what
was gonna happen either but like now I'm
like very sad in my way like I've been
on tour for six months now it's like
very much a stand-up show but like
people come and they think it's like
time for them to hang out with their
friends and talk loud and
disrespectfully and I just I really
wanna let you guys know like it's a
stand-up show so it's like you have to
be quiet and you can't be on your phone
so like you can't be taking pictures and
it's like I think it's hard for a lot of
chaucer's who like seeing this as like
toasters night out but that's why
there's always a toaster pre-game gonna
toast your post game it's like for the
show like you're supposed to be quiet
and I'm never gonna be the type of
performer who like yells at people on
stage but like don't push me to that
place cuz I might get there I'm not
gonna lie now it's sounding like you're
on your way I have a temper and I like
that you should be like there's a wreath
I just don't like when people yell at
people like unnecessarily just for like
if I'm whispering something you couldn't
like whisper to your friend you need to
say something
yeah like being loud I'm not just in the
first house in the first row you threw
out you know what it's like
I like when like it's still annoying but
like I love when like people like know
what I'm about to say cuz toasters like
you know me they're like they know I'm
gonna say grab a spoon and they shout at
first and it's like you know that's
annoying but
to the camaraderie and I don't hate it
it's like thank you for knowing what I'm
about and being familiar with my brand
but when it's like I'm trying to deliver
a premium joke and it's like I do have
to like remember jokes I want to be
still like improv like and you are
having like a loud conversation that has
nothing to do with me like literally in
the front row like that's where you
should check yourself you know and I
really like I'm torn because I'm like so
grateful to everyone who comes and they
know that they're just having a good
time and I never want to like stop
people from like getting drunk cuz
that's the environment that I cultivate
cultivate but it's like no the boundary
and I feel like in Cleveland that we got
really close to the boundary and they
didn't let it stop me and I still like
was really loved Cleveland loved
everyone and you know it is about
Cleveland the people from Cleveland like
they wanted me to like Cleveland so much
because they wanted you to like it and
that at the meet and greet people were
like do you like Cleveland I'm like
you're also self-conscious like they're
like what are you tell Jackie about
Cleveland like you're tell you liked it
right I don't even get to like find out
that much because we just went straight
Jackie oh no right and we couldn't even
think about Cleveland but I'm here to
tell you like it's very much a place for
you and it's super cute in the street
that the venue was on was like this it
was like a Plaza it's not a street it's
like the street was cobblestone and on
every side of the street was like a bar
a club a comedy club then you pack and
no cars go on it was like very cute
without door seating like it was very
premium how long was the fight like an
hour
oh well it's like the flight itself is
an hour but here's the thing
New York has no [ __ ] respect for
Cleveland and I learned that at
LaGuardia where like literally they put
me at a gate that didn't exist like I'd
never been to this gate before and I've
been to LaGuardia my whole life I have
never [ __ ] been to this gate they get
on the plane they're like literally leap
they left us there for like three hours
before we actually took off they didn't
tell us anything the pilot was like I
don't know why they're not letting this
sir I'm like it's cuz we're going to
Cleveland but it's because everyone in
Cleveland is so relaxed that we're no
rush to get there right but like
somebody have another flight to
Cleveland that would never happen I so
they made us wait like an extra hour at
the gate it was so annoying and I was
just like playing on my phone and I was
in first class so like I was I'm worried
about like charging my phone at the gate
and when we actually got on the plane
all I had was a USB I didn't have an
outlet so I was like oh my phone's about
to die on this flight and I literally
just had a cord and literally the man
next to me like heard me you like
talking to Ben on the phone complaining
about anything I gave to me wow that
would like never happen on the flight to
New York
no of course huh
oh my god I didn't even remember how
Jackie O no mo kicked off with my iPad
did you see this crazy I sit in my seat
on the plane I go to take out all my
belongings for the trip in my iPads not
thing set up shop I set up shop my
husband on my back I remember taking it
out in security which is annoying you
shouldn't have to take out an iPad by
the way like it's not a computer it's a
big phone but you don't know a pre-check
I don't have TSA PreCheck like because
I'm just like I don't enjoy traveling so
I'm not gonna like become a world like a
traffic traveller okay like a blur as a
blur so oh but I actually I did have
something premium like a premium line to
go through but not pre-check whatever I
take out my iPad and that's the thing I
was traveling with friends I was we were
so excited hopped up I forgot to take my
iPad out of the bin mind you JFK has no
respect for Bahamas they put us at a
gate all the way down they weren't even
seats my gate was it um it was like in
the B row I think but it was the last
month against the window to go down the
escalator you always have to go down the
escalator whose JetBlue terminal so it's
different then I'm sorry I was thinking
with something else so it was all the
way down one row at the end by the
windows the gate didn't even have seats
was literally one in the corner I'm
sitting on the plane and I'm like oh my
god I don't have my iPad it's not
security
what do I do I go up to the part I'm
like I left my I've had a security come
and go got it they were like if you get
on the plane you can't get back on right
and I don't like if they leave they can
leave without you right so I was group a
and like some of the people in my party
were group D so I'm trying to call
Olivia no she and I was like waiting for
her to pick up as I'm waiting voicemail
and she steps on the plane and she's
there in front but thank God because I
was like I left my iPad it like the
pilot comes out so cute always I was
like I left my iPad at the gate like Amy
please go down and get it it's 1026 he
was like okay doors close at 10:38 like
go okay if you can make it back in time
they were like well you can't leave your
stuff on the plane and Olivia was like I
will be responsible for the stress if we
leave it i stuff I run out at 10:28 I
run all the way down sprinting sprint
Ang's birthday I go to security and like
everyone's so busy and I don't know how
to be like excuse me so I'm like I
literally muster up all my courage I'm
like hello am I left my iPad here
they're like the pink one I was like yes
they knew exactly what was talking about
they got it I had to like do my passcode
in front of them DaVinci Code though I
get it I run back 10:30 Wow they were so
impressed
literally the pilot came out as to how
much
shutting um I putting catch my breath
the entire fight I kept like coughing it
felt like a dress it's like blood it's
like when your throat is so dry eating
saliva can make it well oh my god the
whole flight like I had so much
adrenaline like I couldn't sleep or
anything I couldn't believe I got it and
everyone on the flight like we were the
bachelorette party with the hats and the
iPad and everyone just like we were and
it was just so so embarrassing we go on
the plane on the way home same flight
attendants they were like how was your
Bachelorette this thing is great yeah
much better than my iPad I couldn't
believe that happened that's so not like
me like to be forgetting like I'm not
like you but he's because I was like in
line with Kendall we're having a great
time I'm not like so excited that's
right we can have a lot of time right so
I just forgot about it and I just I
can't believe I got it back like I just
I I started to make peace without my
iPad I was like okay I won't have an
iPad anymore it was an excessive
purchase to begin with
someone had to just say obviously about
my Cleveland comment lol I was there and
I really didn't think we were that
disruptive then again I wasn't in the
first row then again you also weren't
performing so right just don't say what
Shana anyways now that it's been a full
hour and a half of an amazing premium
show I can have literally over an hour
and a half we have to go now we have to
go we have to go record another episode
for patreon god I need to just like I
love doing patreon because I get to wear
sweatpants and I'm just like a better
person no it's like it's it's just a
different vibe it's the relaxed us we're
just like actually shooting the [ __ ]
like we went on your couch as opposed to
like here really good morning meal
anyway it means to sit up straight
exactly an Theo's there and he takes
everything we're premium thank you guys
so much for tuning in to the most
prestigious morning show that went so
long today thank you so much for just
dealing with us dealing with Peter
Krause it has been an honor a pleasure
and an experience to serve you this
morning we are back tomorrow with just
another premium episode we'll be doing
gear toasters so make sure to email to
your toasters at gmail.com and that's
really all we got for you this was the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on Facebook and
YouTube so make sure you like us on
Facebook and you subscribe to us on
YouTube but if you're a commuter you
don't have that computer life you can
listen to us as a podcast on the podcast
or on Spotify stitcher anywhere you can
listen podcast so thank you so much for
subscribing over there have an amazing
day
you